[Music]
the analyze gene list feature can be
used to investigate a list of protein
or small molecule identifiers with or
without expression data
the tool performs over-representation in
pathway topology analysis on the input
data
the submission process recognizes many
types of identifiers
as part of the pre-analysis they are
mapped to react home molecules
the ideal identifiers to use are uniprot
ids for proteins
chebi ids for small molecules and either
hgnc gene symbols or ensemble ids for
dna
or rna molecules as these are our main
external reference sources for proteins
in small molecules
there are two types of data format that
can be submitted
to submit the qualitative data the data
should be a single column of identifiers
such as uniprot ids
gene symbols or chebi ids
they are matched to react home pathways
and tested for over-representation
and pathway topology to submit the
quantitative data
the data should have a column of
identifiers as before and one or more
additional columns of numbers such as
expression or dose response values
this will be recognized as quantitative
data and an additional overlay process
will be run along with over
representation
selecting the continue button on the
analysis submission form brings you to
an options page
several popular proteomics tools
generate results that contain a mixture
of human and other species identifiers
when the default option of project to
human is selected
all non-human identifiers in your query
are converted to their human orthologous
equivalents
as reactome pathways represent human
events
this conversion will maximize the
chances of a successful match to a
reactor
pathway however you may want to uncheck
this box
if your query represents data from an
infected tissue such as a mixture of
human and microbial identifiers
to prevent conversion of non-human
identifiers to human
uncheck the box the include interactor's
option is unchecked by default
with this option selected reacton
pathways are expanded by including all
protein protein
interactors from the intact database for
every protein represented by the pathway
this can greatly increase the size of
the pathway and extend it to include
proteins that would not otherwise be
represented
which maximizes the chances of matching
your submitted identifiers to the
resulting expanded pathways
however the risk of this pathway
expansion is that the expanded protein
set has not been verified by manual
curation and review
you should understand that intact
interactions may be false positives due
to artifacts resulting from the
technology
used with no biological relevance
for single column input list of protein
or small molecule identifiers
over representation and pathway topology
analyses are performed
the names of the columns are explained
when you hover over the column name on
the react home web page
analysis results are shown in the
analysis tab within the details panel
all reacton pathways are shown in blocks
of 20 pathways
ordered by ascending false discovery
rate or fdr value obtained from
over-representation analysis
in addition the number of molecules
matched to total number of molecules and
fdr values are added to the right side
of pathway names in the pathway
hierarchy panel
reactions that contain any of the
matching molecules are boxed in orange
when you click on the name of a pathway
in the analysis tab
the pathway hierarchy will expand to
show it and its name will be highlighted
in dark blue
if it has sub pathways you can use the
plus buttons to the left of the pathway
name to reveal sub pathways and
reactions
analysis results can be filtered for
various factors
including pathway size significance
threshold
p-value and species using the
funnel-shaped filter icon on the top
right corner of the details panel
by default all molecules are used for
over-representation analysis
subtypes of molecule can be selected
from a drop-down list in the filter
option
selecting these subsets will redisplay
results that consider
only the selected molecular subtype
another option in the filter allows
users to ignore disease pathways for the
analysis
as it might skew the results in some
cases
the analysis tab in the details panel
has three buttons on its left
by default the results button is
selected
below this is the not found button that
indicates the number of submitted
identifiers that were not successfully
matched to molecules in react home
click on the button to produce a list if
a significant portion of the identifiers
could not be matched to pathways then
either the identifiers are not
compatible to use with reactome and you
should replace them with something more
suitable
or the identifiers represent molecules
that are not found in our pathways
but might be connected to a known or
unknown definable process
analysis results are also reflected in
the diagrams of pathways and reactions
in the diagram panel above the details
panel
under the network view each pathway in
the network view of pathways is colored
in different shades of yellow according
to the over-representation significance
or p-value
a selection bar at the bottom of the
diagram panel will allow you to color
pathways
based on the coverage which reflect the
number of matched entities
instead of p-value under the voronoi
view
the voronoi map view show the same
information as in the network view
but this view is easier for users to
visualize the results
textbook style diagrams represent
analysis results within the label for
sub pathways
the label background changes from blue
to white a yellow band is used to
indicate the proportion of the pathway
that is represented in the query data
set
a gray bar above the label indicates the
number of pathway entities that is
represented in the query data set
the total number of entities in the
pathway and the fdr corrected
probability score
under the sbgn diagram entities in the
diagram
are colored yellow if they were
represented in the submitted data set
complexes sets and sub pathway icons are
colored to represent the proportion of
the molecules they contain that are
represented in the submitted identifier
list
to examine the details of a complex or
set hover the mouse pointer over it
a small blue triangle will appear on the
right side
select this to open an information panel
the uppermost tab on the left size will
be selected the molecules represented by
the complex or set or displayed as a
table
with a yellow shaded background if they
were in the query data set
if you submit data in a format that
includes columns of numeric values
following a first column of protein
compound or other suitable identifiers
such as probe ids
the analysis tool will interpret your
data as expression data
the numeric values are used to color
objects in pathway diagrams
the results page is very similar to that
of a qualitative input analysis with
single column list of identifiers with
additional columns in the analysis
details
these extra columns represent the
submitted expression values
clicking on a pathway name launches the
relevant pathway diagram
things to look for include objects in
the pathway diagram are colored
according to the numeric values
submitted
the gradient yellow to blue colors are
based on a scale
which is represented in a bar on the
right hand side
when zoomed out objects are colored to
reflect the average of the values
submitted for the molecules
when zoomed in complexes and sets will
resolve to colored bands
representing the values of individual
molecules
the experiment browser toolbar is used
to step through the columns of your data
such time points or disease progression
as you move across the different columns
the pathway diagrams will recolor to
reflect the new values